We all knew it was going to happen because
all the signs were there, but it's now getting
into overdrive.
Trump allies are now reportedly raising millions
of dollars to pay to find damaging information
about journalists who are seen as unfriendly
to Donald Trump and the Trump administration.
And to then ideally use that information to
create antagonism campaigns against journalists,
potentially to try to get journalists fired.
Certainly there will be harassment from Trumpists
on the basis of this opposition research campaign
against members of the free press that Trump
allies are undertaking.
And you can't miss the forest for the trees
here.
This is a hallmark of authoritarian dictatorships.
This is a hallmark of police states.
This is everything that is the opposite of
what the United States is supposed to be.
This is Putin.
Like this is Duterte like, and we knew Trump
liked it.
We knew Trump liked going after the media,
Trump going after specific media outlets,
even specific journalists in some cases, the
fake news moniker applied very haphazardly,
not to fake news, but merely to anything that
doesn't say glowing effusive things about
Donald Trump.
And this is now an attempt to formalize attacks
on individual and specific journalists.
These are attempts in practice to silence
or ruin the lives of people who are reporting
critically about the president of the United
States.
One of the most important things that a free
and open press can do and should be doing,
axios has obtained the fundraising pitch,
which has been deployed to get people to donate
to this cause, the cause that will ultimately
gather information that can be used to harass
or discredit journalists and reporters.
Can you imagine getting an email and being
so disconnected from reality, having your
priorities or your morality so backwards,
having such a fundamental misunderstanding
of what it is that is important in the United
States of America.
When it comes to a free press, imagine getting
an email saying we are raising money to go
after journalists, uh, that are, that are
antagonizing us and saying, you know what,
that sounds like something I want to donate
to.
And apparently it isn't enough to just call
certain news outlets, fake news and go after
them.
Trump's allies now want to go after specific
reporters.
One of the people involved is a republican
consultant named Arthur Schwartz.
The primary targets of this campaign are said
to be an listen to this.
CNN and MSNBC.
Not surprising all of the broadcast networks.
Okay.
The New York Times, The Washington Post, both
of which have been doing extraordinarily good,
just plain old fashioned investigative work
about this administration, buzzfeed and the
Huffington Post.
And this is the kicker.
Anyone else routinely included in what a Trump
supporter sees as bias and misinformation
in their coverage of Donald Trump?
Meaning it could be anybody.
I spoke to a couple of friends in Washington
DC who are not, not Republicans, they're not
directly involved with this, but they've been
in touch with people who have knowledge of
what's going on.
They told me independent media journalists
that are seen as particularly antagonistic
to the president are not out of the realm
of possibility for being targeted and harassed.
I am not.
This is not a delusion of grander where I
think I am on Trump's radar or on the the
list of people that this group is going to
come after.
I've merely been told that it is not just
corporate media that is on the radar in terms
of this campaign.
So let's immediately put to rest.
The Trump is talking point, which I've already
seen floating around that this is no big deal.
This is the same thing.
Media matters.
Does media matters, criticizes and publishes
media clips.
They aren't going about trying to attack and
discredit individual reporters in the way
that is being suggested here that Trump's
allies want to do.
We've seen this before and where we've seen
these attempts to harass and target individual
journalists.
It's places where human rights have been decimated
in any number of ways.
Russia, World War Two era Germany, the Philippines,
Venezuela.
This is if we allow it to happen, the normalization
of fascistic behavior, it doesn't mean we
are a dictatorship, but it is authoritarian
fascistic behavior, attack media as fake news.
Treat them poorly, kick out individual journalists,
talk about journalism licenses and lawsuits
against media and then smear campaigns against
individual journalists for being journalists
and doing their jobs.
This is, you know, color what you want.
Is it North Korea?
Is it stolen?
Is it all of them?
And a word, by the way, to the gun nuts.
You know how the gun not say we need guns
to defend ourselves from a government that
becomes tyrannical.
This is actually the type of thing that if
one believed the government would become tyrannical,
would be sort of at the top of the list, starting
to clamp down on a free and independent press.
And yet I'm not hearing from any of the gun
nuts that they're worried about this.
In fact, a lot of the Trumpist gun nuts love
this because they fall in hook, line and sinker.
They've drank the Koolaid to borrow a term
from Jim Jones.
Uh, they've drank the cooler, not a term,
but an action, I guess.
Uh, they have drank the Koolaid on the media
is the enemy and we need to be going after
them rather than defending them because it
is a form of potential government tyranny.
This is a form of tyranny by special interest
group, to put it another way, but it happens
to be one that the gun nuts don't seem acutely
effected by in a way that makes them realize,
Oh man, our threats, our fears about tyrannical
government, they're actually not the kind
that we really needed the guns to defend against.
But this is starting to look like a form of
government tyranny.
Understand that the biggest threats to Trump's
presidency are the things that make the United
States what it is.
A free press is a threat to Donald Trump's
presidency because he needs to hide the truth
to justify his reelection.
If people know the truth, there's no path
to reelection because his record is so atrocious.
High voter turnout is a threat to Donald Trump's
presidency.
Well, we know why that is.
Trump benefits from people not voting or not
being able to vote.
This is real.
This is happening now and it has to be stopped
in its tracks before it even gets going.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
de Pacman.
Let me know what you think.
Follow the show on Twitter at David Pakman
show and make sure to sign up if you have
Amazon prime.
Subscribe with twitch prime at twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
This is free for everyone who has Amazon prime,
but it supports the work
that we do.
twitch.tv/david Pacman,